Here's the car painted with diffuse paint. Something you probably never see in
the real world. With just a directional light on representing the sun. Notice
how the area in shadow is entirely dark. Filling this with a solid ambient
light wouldn't look much better. The final result, showing the surrounding
environment in shadows gives a highly realistic effect. This demo runs at
interactive rates. Looking at demos like this gets me excited to add another
ten lessons on various topics that have to do with texturing. For example, I'm
feeling a bit guilty that I haven't talked about high-dynamic-range textures,
HDR for short. The quick version about HDR textures is that they're used to
capture a wide range of lighting levels, basically, more bits per channel. This
wide range is particularly useful for environment maps as the light sources in
the scene can in reality be magnitudes brighter than other objects. Think of
the sun. These textures allow a variety of materials to use them in a more
physically believable fashion, and also, avoid banding artifacts due to
precision limits. For example, some objects such as plastics mostly pick up
just bright lights as reflections and little else. HDR textures allow us to use
the same environment map for these materials as well as highly reflective metal
surfaces.